oh wow well we have had a lot of them in
this matchup between
dubois and carlson but the status is
that if magnus wins this game
they will be equal the winner of the
last game will be the winner
if they tie that game whoa what's
happening oh my goodness me he has
made a blunder okay he didn't trust that
he didn't calculate he didn't trust that
his king was safe
and now we've seen a turnaround could
could magnus carlsen be knocked out
magnus carlson's suddenly
suddenly losing he's missed this next
move white i think only has one move to
win
um it's either win or loss here for
white there's no in between there's no
middle ground
white needs to push a pawn up to attack
the black knight and he's found it
okay oh my and magnus carlsen suddenly
going down to defeat the black king i
said it was safe
but he's missed this last move black as
magnus carlsen he's put his queen on a
bad square the black queen boxed in
he should have brought it around to try
and get at the white king from behind
he's missed this move magnus carson is
on the
verge of elimination now if magnus
carlsen loses this game he will be out
daniel dubo will be
heading to the semi-final wow and we can
see it on magnus now he
definitely wow look at him he realizes
he blundered
yeah total blunder i mean it's super
difficult to see that your king
will be safe in the corner out there
in the open and that you just black
needed just to activate the queen and
have some counter threats and uh now
magnus
has advanced the pawn but i think it's
all over yeah and
actually we had this scenario yesterday
with magnus his king being attacked by a
queen and a rook
the black king is not safe magnus castle
also
seconds
his hands in the air he has beaten the
world champion after
three games in the second quarter final
match he is ready for the semi-final
magnus carlsen is out the world champion
is
out